that's the way it is so they'll cancel
us grant they'll cancel free one the
ward that freed the slaves they'll
cancel Abraham Lincoln the president who
freed the slaves they'll cancel st.
Junipero Serra they'll cancel Jesus
himself okay they'll cancel all of these
people now the cancel culture is have
any effect beyond this there was a
person that I had never heard of until
yesterday who is one of the most
prominent youtubers her name is jenna
Marbles and a very important stuff jenna
Marbles jenna Marbles has a YouTube
channel of 20 million people
20 million subscribers she's been around
making videos for now for 10 years
and they're just kind of funny videos
well she's quitting now she's quitting
the whole thing because people are
digging up old videos of hers that she
had deleted where I guess she told some
jokes that she now thinks her offensive
and they're trying to ruin her
reputation 10 years after the fact after
they were deleted here is her tearful
goodbye and I don't want to put anything
out in the world it's gonna hurt anybody
so I need to be done with this channel
for now or forever I don't know so
alright good talk see you guys Miss
marbles is apparently such a prominent
youtuber that she actually has a statue
at Madame Tussauds Museum although
certainly that statue at this point all
the statues are coming down and
especially that one of her that line she
says I don't want to put anything out in
the world that hurts anybody this is the
problem what we are now being told is
that if you if a person has done
anything bad ever anything that is not
perfect that is grounds to tear down the
statue but consider the argument in all
of these shootings and all the shootings
that allegedly led to the protests
Candis Owens got in a lot of trouble
because she pointed out that the media
haven't told the whole story about some
of these officer-involved killings and
and that in some cases the people who
were killed had a long criminal rap
sheet maybe they were committing crimes
at the moment that they were killed the
response to that the popular response is
how dare you bring up that person's past
that person's past has nothing to do
with what happened in that moment and we
shouldn't judge a man based on the bad
things that he did in his life even if
if they've done years and years of long
terrible things beat their wife abused
their kids we can't judge them for any
of that we should only judge them on
their their few best moments and yet the
statue argument the canceled culture
argument is doesn't matter how much good
you do in your life if you've committed
one or two bad things that's what you
should be judged by the double standard
is absurd and it's obviously incoherent
but we are long past the stage of making
finely tuned arguments this is about
brute political force this is about an
ideological group clubbing everybody on
the head for their own interests whether
their arguments make any sense that
isn't the point this is a bare-knuckle
brawl at least until November and I
think unfortunately one side of this is
gonna go wishy-washy and buy into the
the lying premises of guys like Andrew
Cuomo and the anarchists and the valid
admitted Marxists who are running bln
and they'll say well I just don't want
to hurt anybody please don't come after
me I'll quit we can't quit folks we
can't quit this is the fight we're in it
now and you can either stand up and and
fight that fight and hopefully preserve
America before they tear the whole thing
down preserve American solidarity before
they divide us up completely or you can
surrender
[Music]
you
[Music]